well metro police patrols usually
involve watching for crime and
protecting the public but now officers
are doing their part to deliver food in
addition to that service mary dane
villasa joining us live this morning
with a look at these patrol packs and
mary jane these are just so important
and so helpful to so many folks
well john heather absolutely i mean
these patrol packs are such a good idea
they're filled with canned goods
non-perishable items really anywhere
from pasta canned vegetables granola
bars and even a can opener the idea is
to provide a meal for families who need
it facing tough times and officers can
pass out these bags while on duty these
patrol packs were donated by an
anonymous donor through convoy of hope
it's a nonprofit focused on providing
humanitarian services metro has received
13 pallets of bags so a patrol pack
could go into every police car
throughout the valley
sometimes we go out and it's you know a
miscellaneous phone call where you
realize that the it was a young child
that just needed it was playing on the
phone and then through your
investigation or through talking to the
family you realize that you know
something as small as this could help
them because we know those officers see
people in need all day long and we've
heard so many stories about officers
taking their own money going to grocery
stores buying supplies and then giving
it to people who need it
metro received 1300 patrol packs and
have already started giving them out
every patrol area command was given a
whole pallet which means that's there's
85 to 100 packs in there depending on
the size of that area metro tells me no
they hope to continue to give out more
of these patrol packs every year they're
really great to give out around the
holidays you know thanksgiving christmas
even more so now when it's hot and
people don't have a means to get to the
grocery store reporting live mary jane
valeza live local now